how much money are you making in 2016 I
was making 100K 2019 was my best year
ever I probably grossed around 800k wow
but that was me going ham I was at
conferences every month I was giving
talks I was doing like six to seven
videos a month almost all of them were
branded and then 2020 happened and I had
a rough time with 2020 so I've kind of
been like building back the blocks my
income went back to like early days
basically in the beginning I was like
how do you get back to 2019 Sarah High
these people and scale and do all this
when I hated my life doing that I was
like I don't need 800k a year what do
you actually need I need money for door
Dash I need money to fly first class
because I I'm a homebody I hang out with
my cat and like to be comfortable I hate
flying and that's about it so I'm like
if you make a few six figes a year your
life is going to be exactly how you like
to live it so I would say I I'm floating
around that area as general netw worth